from rollingstone.com oh boy Hollywood
stars musicians call for release of
Hamas hostages in letter to President
Biden you know what the the letter is
basically saying it's it's saying Joe
Biden declar war on Iran okay but let's
read they say scores of Hollywood actors
musicians Comedians and other
entertainment figures signed an open
letter to President Biden on Monday
calling for the release of all hostages
Hamas has taken among the hundreds of
signatories were Amy Schumer Jerry
Seinfeld Jus Timberlake Madonna Katy
Perry Bradley Cooper the letter is part
of a campaign called No hostage Left
Behind which seeks the release of more
than 200 hostages taken during the Hamas
attack on
Israel now my question is what is the
ask Hamas has hostages so you wrote a
letter to Joe Biden it's simple they're
saying go to war and do whatever you
have to
do the anti-war party is saying go to
war and do whatever you have to do you
know having run counterterrorism for
president Trump and the hostage
portfolios and bringing home 54 guys we
kind of know how to do it and this
this this Americans have been taken Joe
Biden has brought home none of them the
Qatari government has brought home four
Americans wow four yeah and this this
warmongering machine the Liberals are
saying yeah let's do another Afghanistan
Hollywood hasn't been anti-war in a long
time they've been anti-American for a
long time uh and pro and pro-islam
during uh Iraq and Afghanistan lots of
movies bear that out but they're not
anti-war not not in any sense of the
word and right now the I think it's
worse than that for a lot of this I I
don't even know if it's so much that
they think that far ahead I think that
they just know that these are issues
that they need to have an opinion on
because their public Persona requires
them to be seen and heard talking about
things it's a way to stay relevant they
have to be on it it's ridiculous I mean
if you actually about anything like this
would you make it so like I need my I
need to post this tweet so people engage
with it so they see that I'm empathetic
I mean it's really ultimately
narcissistic and about themselves I
wonder though if Hollywood uh how much
of Hollywood acknowledges that they're
not War anymore it's the same thing with
the Democratic party being like we're
countercultural and you're like no
you're not you you are the mainstream
force and you Market this all the time
and yet you claim that you're sort of
this weird Underdog when you're
obviously not their brains don't process
that at all they still believe that
they're the counterculture they still
believe that they're the party of
antiwar they also believe that they're
part they're the party of the of the uh
the little guy rather than the party of
big Banks and in big money but for a lot
of like I've watched every one of these
celebrities have the most artfully
written response that supposed to
appease both sides only to watch them
one by one get taken out instantly
because they don't realize I think a lot
of it is not being fully in touch with
your audience it's like they don't
realize the size of their platforms and
just how actually diverse the amount of
people yeah you're going to get soccer
moms who like your stuff but you're also
going to get young leftists you're going
to get they don't realize that no matter
what you say it's not enough it will
never be enough because the most vocal
of either side will come at you no
matter how how neutral you remain the
best thing you could do is not say
anything but they are too addicted to
the attention and they need the and they
need the rub and they self-important
they think the world needs their opinion
which is is challenging I mean it's
similar to a lot of uh politicians who
weigh on an issues that they're actually
probably not that well versed in but
they're saying you know if I don't get
the right Buzz out then no one will pay
attention to me again it's Des I mean
you were talking about this before they
ultimately all want the attention and
that's why I think people fight so hard
to stay in office right mean the fact
that Diane find stayed in office until
she was actually dead is crazy I mean
that is not wanting to give up power I
well it's power and relevance worth like
a hundred some million dollar it was
like a billion she married crazy like a
they were like private jet and I mean
she married a crazy wealthy guy the
other thing is like so in the weeks
leading up to her death she had to sign
over uh Power of Attorney to her
daughter because there's all kinds of
legal disputes over the estate and they
said you know she's really sick this
past year she shingles and some
complications from that and so she needs
the the money for her medical bills I
mean it's it's such a strange thing
where we're having someone who can't
fight their own legal battles but can
still be brought to and from uh Nancy
Pelosi's daughter was pushing her
wheelchair around Congress but she
didn't need to retire no worries she's
going to stay our country is sick that's
disgusting this the thing like I I when
Josie the redhead libertarian was here
she was saying she would want Ron Paul
to be Speaker of the House I love Ron
Paul I think he's great but he is
elderly let him just rest and hang out
with his kids and write interesting
books but do not make him do this dumb
bureaucratic job in Washington until he
dies like this is not the culture I want
and they're the ideological children of
Ron Paul that are available Dave Smith
exists you like Dave Smith make him
speaker of the house and then we are
again expanding this bench of people who
can potentially Le the country in the
right directions let's just not make run
ball work until the end and meanwhile
Mitch McConnell needs to be booted every
15 minutes when he's giving a speech
maybe should the fact that Mitt Romney
is the first person to be like I'll be
in my ' 80s I should step down it's like
the first sensible thing I've ever heard
from him in my life no I'm I'm going to
throw Game of Thrones reference out
there you know this is this is the
circle this is the wheel that
continuously spins and Donald Trump was
the force that broke the wheel he broke
it for a while and robbed all their
people of the rollingstone headlines
robbed these people of these important
jobs and TV interviews and positions
exploited them for the corrupt actors
they are I mean the Insiders trading
alone between Pelosi and fste should be
enough to send them to prison for an
eternity got to get that Pelosi tracker
no get the it's called unusual whales or
something like that I follow all my all
my if you want to invest in stocks just
look at unusual whales CU they are they
are literally citing the upcoming
legislation that these guys are betting
their gambles on and they track it all
and you can go probably like 5 to 7%
return on there um it's but they figured
this out and now it'll probably spread
where they'll be like oh most Americans
have figured it out so you know we're
going to make this illegal but they need
they still make money right so they're
still going to keep doing it that's why
why Congress does they're never going to
write themselves into a law that says oh
well we can't of course not of course
not Gates and AOC teamed up trying to
stop them from being the younger
generation is saying like hey wait maybe
this isn't great it's like telling them
to introduce term limits but but I think
I'm optimistic I'm optimistic because if
you look at Matt Gates the reason he's
able to do what he does is because his
donors are individuals on the internet
that he's got small donors he doesn't
need to go to one man for a million
dollar you can go to a million men for
$1 and women no you're so look whatever
you think about Matt and I've known Matt
a long time about whether he's right to
start this process or wrong process no
no I'm just saying whatever your
position is I agree but I'm saying he
was the only one that I know of that
could go to The Well of the floor in the
house of the representatives and
announce to the world that I have not
accepted
$1 from one lobbyist or one defense
industrial complex organization mind you
Matt has one of the biggest Air Force
bases we have in his home District wow
so for him to go out and say that and
then the chorus of booze comes in and
his response to me was perfect every
single one of those people booing took a
six and seven figure paycheck to their
super packs maxed out donations parties
in DC had them on their Jets and their
planes and they were caught red-handed
with what Donald Trump had caught them
with being the biggest Hypocrites who
are in charge of running our democracy
and I think he's excoriated for it now
because we're in this position where
we'll probably just have Tim P become
speaker but we'll get to that uh we're
in this position where you know they're
like it's a rudderless government I was
like how How well was it steered when
McCarthy what do you you were on the ver
you kicked the Deb ceiling you were
going to give us another CR these
oversight investigations that were
supposed to promise the you know the end
of time um were running were being run
by wet noodles and you weren't
empowering them to enforce their
subpoenas and now we have an exposure I
think it's a big Civics education you
have people paying attention of course
the left's going to come and be like the
Republicans are ruin Governor but hey
right now they they can't pass a CR or
an Omnibus because they can't speak they
can't fund a war either they can't fund
a war they can't write a check to the
Ukraine there I'm seeing I'm seeing a
lot of these conservatives on Twitter be
like what did we really gain from Matt
Gates's stunt and like why did he do
this and I'm just sitting back like you
know all the Libertarians are laughing
because now there's stagnation and
there's no more wasteful spending
because they can't can't write a check
it's not what we gained it's what zinsky
lost dude have you even heard of that
guy in like a no he is so mad about he's
begging he's not happy being the side
piece again no no I remember after all
the stuff like after the October 7th uh
stuff happened in Israel he was like
putting on statements like yes we too
have suffer don't forget that we in
Ukraine we need some money here that
it's that friend who like every time
something bad happens to you he's like
yeah something worse happened to me you
know what would be a good way to get
ukra and I'm not saying there's people
over there that don't need help and
obviously Russia's attacking a lot of
zones but when you go on the interwebs
and you type in like Kev nightclub it's
like Miami Beach have you seen these
freaking parties like my friends have
gone over there do a bunch of work over
there and they're like what war zone
like what are you talking about you
can't have that going on and ask the
world for $500 billion it is funny cuz I
I have like friends that skate in both
Russia and Ukraine and if if you're
hockey guy no it's well I mean hockey
too but it's it's uh skating is like
aggressive but like like like if you if
you were going by their social media
post like their story posts it's like
the ones who are in Ukraine are posting
about fundraising for their go you know
fundraising for the military but then
you see their posts and they're just out
skating at the skate park and I'm like
how is that happening right now no no no
this this is something people don't get
I talk about a bit uh people don't
understand that countries in war are not
every every every place in this country
is at war war you know about but I I I
this is the story everyone's heard me
say at nauseum in Egypt during the
second revolution two blocks away from
taher Square where the revolution is
taking place there's a guy at McDonald's
watching a soccer match like there was a
casino in the Hilton Hotel you were not
allowed to enter if you were an Egyptian
citizen because it's it's what's the
word it's Haram the right word like it's
it's a violation forbidden but uh
tourists were gambling in there playing
roulette crabs Blackjack yeah of course
two blocks away from a revolution where
Apache helicopters are flying over and
there's apcs people are shooting at each
other in the streets and blocks away
nobody cares and and these things become
normalized right I mean think about the
protest in Paris this year there were so
many videos of like these people having
dinner at like whatever cute little cafe
and meanwhile something's on fire and
someone's throwing something through a
window like if if you've been in
Conflict for a year at a certain point
you know Z not going to keep you from
the bars what was the video of like the
girl doing like a Tik Tok dance while a
military coup is going on behind her oh
that's on mymar that's actually bring
Burma yeah there you go that was she was
actually a yoga it was like a yoga thing
or something like that it's even better
you know her you call her sege no no no
it's just like it was great cuz very
current
year I mean especially I know Tim is is
feeling imp passionate about this
subject uh if that conflict has been
going on for actual decad you just live
with it yeah eventually all right thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net